♪ ♪
>> Tucker: OFFICIALS IN
WASHINGTON SPENT TWO YEARS
WAITING FOR THE MUELLER REPORT.
REMEMBER THE ANTICIPATION
QUESTION RIGHT NOW THAT IT IS
OUT, MOST PEOPLE IN D.C. DECIDED
THAT WHILE THEY HATED TRUMP
PASSIONATELY, THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY HATE HIM ENOUGH TO READ
448 PAGES OF TEXT.
THAT IS JUST TOO HARD.
NOW, TRUE BELIEVERS HAVE A
CARTOON VERSION OF THE MUELLER
REPORT.
FOR REAL.
CNN WAS VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
>> COVERS ALL OF THE MAJOR
MOMENTS.
IF AT THE DINNER WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP REQUESTED
LOYALTY FROM AN FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES LOYALTY.
THE OVAL OFFICE SCREAMING MATCH
WHERE THE PRESIDENT DEMANDED
MORE PROTECTION FROM HIS THEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS,
AND YES, IT DOES AS WELL INCLUDE
HIS ORDER TO FIRE ROBERT MUELLE
ROBERT MUELLER.
>> Tucker: IT MAY SEEM ODD TO
DO A BOOK REVIEW OF THE PICTURE
BOOK BUT THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO DO TONIGHT.
DAN BONGINO JOINS US.
A FORMER SECRET SERVICE AGENT,
NEW YORK CITY COP AND A FREQUENT
GUEST ON THE SHOW.
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THESE
PICTURES?
>> NO, BECAUSE I HAVEN'T WANTED
TO LOSE NEURONS AND ABOUT 20 IQ
POINTS BY READING THIS KIND OF
IMBECILITY.
BUT I'M JUST WONDERING, WHEN HE
TELLS ATTORNEY GENERAL DOM BEGAN
TO TEST IT 30 PLUS HOURS OR WHAT
IF THEY INCLUDE THE PETER STRZOK
IF THEY INCLUDE THE PETER STRZOT
IF THEY INCLUDE THE PETER STRZOX
IF THEY INCLUDE THE PETER STRZOW
IF THEY INCLUDE THE PETER STRZOE
IF THEY INCLUDE THE PETER STRZOH
IF THEY INCLUDE THE PETER STRZOT
IF THEY INCLUDE THE PETER STRZOL
IF THEY INCLUDE THE PETER STRZOS
HIS GIRLFRIEND OVER TEXT, I
DON'T THINK THERE IS ANYTHING
THERE.
OR HERE'S ANOTHER DOOZY, WHEN
PETER STRZOK'S GIRLFRIEND, THE
FBI LAWYER TOLD A CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE AS MUELLER IS
APPOINTED THAT THIS CASE COULD
STILL BE LITERALLY NOTHING!
WE'VE BEEN SPYING ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, YOU
APPOINT BOB MUELLER, I WONDER IF
THIS COULD BE LITERALLY NOTHING
IS IN THE ACTUAL COMIC BOOK.
JUST CHECKING WITH THE WRITERS.
CALL ME, TEXT ME, I WOULD LOVE
TO KNOW.
>> Tucker: I SUSPECT IT'S NOT.
THAT MIGHT GET IN THE WAY.
>> IF I AM A BETTING MAN, YOU'RE
RIGHT.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT'S
SO MUELLER IS COMING FOR THE
CONFERENCE, HE WILL BE ASKED
QUESTIONS, WHAT SHOULD HE BE
ASKED?
SPEAK OF THE FIRST QUESTION HE
HAS TO BE ASKED IS WHAT EXACTLY
DID YOU FIND OUT THAT COLLUSION
WAS THE BIGGEST LITTLE GOAL HOAX
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
AT MY RESEARCH SOME OF THE I WAS
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR PROJECT, NO
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR PROJECT, NL
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR PROJECT, NT
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR PROJECT, NR
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR PROJECT, NA
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR PROJECT, NN
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR PROJECT, NM
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR PROJECT, NY
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR PROJECT, NO
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR PROJECT, NF
2070 BECAUSE THAT IS WHEN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL EXPOSES
MUELLER'S TO THE TEXT ABOUT
SMELLY WALMART PEOPLE AND TRUMP,
SO MUELLER MUST KNOW THERE WAS
SOMETHING GOING ON THERE.
WE MUST KNOW WHEN HE FOUND OUT
AND WHAT HE WAS DOING FOR 600
DAYS AFTER HE FOUND OUT HE WAS
INVESTIGATING THE BIGGEST HOAX
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> Tucker: THAT IS A SOLID
QUESTION, I WONDER IF ANYONE
WILL ASK IT.
WE CAN'T LET YOU LEAVE YET.
NORMALLY WE MEET ON FRIDAYS BUT
TONIGHT, WE'VE GOT A SPECIAL
MIDWEEK EDITION OF THE
DAN BONGINO NEWS EXPLOSION.
[LAUGHS]
TOP STORY THIS WEEK, DAN HAS
SOMETHING SPECIAL FOR US.
HE IS GIVING US THE TOP
QUESTIONS HE WANTS MUELLER TO
FACE.
THAT IS THE FIRST ONE.
WE'VE ALREADY GOT ONE.
GIVE US THE NEXT ONE YOU WOULD
ASK.
TO SPEAK OF THE NEXT ONE IS
IMPORTANT, THIS IS A GOOD
ONE.
SOMEONE NEEDS TO ASK BOB MUELLER
WHY IT IS THAT HE LEFT OUT ALL
OF THIS EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE IN
THIS REPORT?
I LOVE WHEN THE LEFT -- BY THE
WAY, I DID READ THE REPORT
MULTIPLE TIMES BECAUSE I HAVE TO
FOR MY RESEARCH PROJECT I'M
DOING HERE BUT WHAT IS
FASCINATING AS HE LEAVES AT ALL
THE INFORMATION THAT INDICATES
THAT THE TRUMP TEAM IS IN FACT
INNOCENT.
I'LL GIVE YOU ONE EASY EXAMPLE,
THESE DREADED CONTACTS BETWEEN
PAUL MANAFORT IN THIS GUY
CONSTANTINE WHO HAS CONNECTIONS
TO RUSSIA AND IS MADE TO SOUND
ALL NEFARIOUS.
BY THE TIME YOU'RE DONE READING
YOU ARE LIKE OH, MY GOSH,
PAUL MANAFORT IS LIKE AGENT X
FROM THE X-MEN OR SOMETHING.
HE SOLD US OUT.
TILL YOU FIND OUT LATER WHAT IS
NOT IN THE MUELLER REPORT,
CONSTANTINE WAS A SOURCE FOR THE
OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT FOR A
LONG TIME BEFORE THE END NOBODY
BROUGHT UP ANY OF THESE ISSUES.
ONE MORE QUICK ONE, THE ATTORNEY
WHO SHOWS UP AT TRUMP TOWER FOR
THE EVIL TRUMP TOWER MEETING
WHERE THEY TALK ABOUT RUSSIAN
ADOPTION, THE ATTORNEY WHO SHOWS
UP WAS WORKING FOR THE TEAM
HIRED BY MRS. CLINTON TO GAIN
RESEARCH ON TRUMP.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO FIND THAT
ANYWHERE IN THE MUELLER REPORT,
WHICH IS REALLY THE TRUMP OP-ED.
THAT IS WHAT IT IS.
THE LONGEST OP-ED IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT THAT WAS
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S KNEES OR